في هذا المبنى وفي الطابق الخامس عشر
تحديدا سيقف اول رئيس امام قاضي بتهمه
جنائيه بعد ان يستوفي المراحل القانونيه
في كل غرفه ولن يشفى ليديه من الاصفاد غير
منصبه السابق ربما هي جلسه بروتوكوليه
وسيغادر بعدها بكفاله اما بالنسبه للترومب
المحاكمه بكل اركانها مجرد مشهد من حملته
الانتخابيه صراعه مع العداله سيستمر لابعد
من الانتخابات لكن الاضواء التي سلطت
عليها وضعت اخر اللمسات على دور الضحيه
الذي لبسه منذ ان غادر البيت الابيض
ولا مخلصه لامريكا من بطش الديمقراطيين
غير العوده وهي كافيه لتكون برنامج
انتخابيا بالمحتوى والعنوان قد لا يحتاج
ترومب حتى الان لانزال المحتاجين افواجا
الى الشوارع وهو الذي يستعرض شعبيته في كل
تجمع انتخابي خاصه وان اموالهم تفي بالغرض
النداء اثمر ثمانيه ملايين دولار جمعتها
التبرعات المخصصه لمواجهه متاعب ترامب في
نيويورك سخاء الانصار وجه اخر للشعبيه
استطلاعات الراي كشفت دعما جمهوريا مطلقا
غير ان الخصوم اعتبروها زوبعه في بيت
الحزب الجمهوري لغيره
الفوز في الانتخابات العامه يحتاج لكسب
الاصوات المتارجحه لكن الكثير ممن لم
يحسموا امرهم بعد سئموا مما وصفوه بفائض
الدراما والفوضى التي شوهت سوره البلاد
جزء اخر اعتبر مصيرا الرئيس السابق اهانه
لامريكا ويعبر عن تطويع القانون لتصفيه
حسابات سياسيه الاكيد ان تشومب قطع خطوات
في طريق الفوز بالانتخابات التمهيديه بل
احيانا مدفوعا بدعم اقوى المنافسين لكن
النصر الاكبر قد يحتاج تفاصيل اصغر لم
تنكشف بعد